bushet can get you 90 feet guerrello can
get you three runs
with one swing down ball through the
hole
oh wendell with two nice play throw to
first not in time
guerrero ends up with a base hit and an
rbi
the blue jays have a one nothing lead
fill up that
runners in scoring position batting
average picking on this ball no chance
for the third baseman to get it joey
wendell
full stretch as he actually catches that
ball behind him
to oscar hernandez the cleanup hitter
still nobody out runners at first and
second
ground ball base hit through the hole
they're waving buchet around
he's going to come in to score there'll
be no throw another
opposite field base hit for the blue
jays and they've got a two-nothing lead
simeon's had a terrific month of may
with his
14th extra base hit in the month of may
he leads the majors in extra base hits
jimmy hits it high in the air kirmar
back ball's going
get up ball get out of here off the wall
davis is in the score simeon is headed
for third
and he'll get there with his second
extra base hit of the ball game
that's his first triple of the season
yeah maybe you could throw a breaking
ball earlier this season
and he doesn't hit it kiermeier
initially didn't
see it and again the wind is going to
take this ball
up and away from him and q meyer one of
the best center feeders i've ever seen
thought he had a chance
this could be two short hop it might be
three
they're gonna go and they get a rose
arena and good job by espinal
he recognized that there was a force out
at second so he had the tag of rosarina
but that could have been a triple play
because the runner in rosarina had to
hold up on the
line drive that was short hopped by
simeon
so now lau raised with a man at
[Applause]
first
there's a drive back into right field
and that's going to carry out of here
line drive home run off the bat of
brandon lau
and suddenly the rays get on the board
a two-run shot and just like that
it's three to two what how that turns
the situation around that pitch middle
in
up trying to go away but it never got
there
and right at the belt that's a bullet
too you're going to see you're going to
see this
all weekend i'm glad he
had an infield base hit his first time
up and drove in a run he's now got 33
ribbies for
this season
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was a home run from the moment he
hit it they get
one of those runs back quickly 4-2 jays
you know you're locked in again against
a guy who can throw 100 miles an hour
you're ahead in the count
breaking ball upper parts of the strike
zone
full extension level swing
swings through the baseball and that's
how you can hit that ball
that far brandon hit the home run in the
third inning and that has accounted for
all of the ray's
scoring tonight there's a high
shot deep into right he is going to do
it again
home run on the roof beyond the wall out
there and right and he makes it
a one-run ball game he homered off the
left-hander anthony kaye
he is homered off the left-hander travis
bergen
another fastball elevated leaking right
back to the middle of the plate
similar location that he's already taken
one out takes this one a little bit
further out a little higher up right off
the roof
marcus simmons after a terrific start to
this
night and now he is head one up to left
field
marcus is on fire
[Music]
wow that's how you turn on an inside
fastball
glass now's got one of the best
fastballs in all of baseball but not
tonight against
the blue jays and especially marcus
simeon
and guess what for the cycle he's got
all the hard ones out of the way
he's got a double a triple and a home
run
and we're in the fifth and g man choi
comes out of the dugout to pinch hit for
brasso
and now this pit swung on and drilled
deep to riot and joy
has done it g-man choi
a pinch-hit home run a two-run
shot and just like that the rays have
tied this game
how about g man joy
it really has been incredible the way he
has swung the bat
since coming back middle of the plate 90
miles an hour g-man right here lets you
know as that ball comes off the bat
he's going to flip that bat like yep i
got him
look how deep
another rays and the blue jays are gonna
move into extra innings
tied five five at the end of nine
well they send wendell down to first
and they'll pitch to mejia with the
bases loaded
and he shoots this one deep to right
that baby's going to get
out of here grand slam off the bat
of mejia on the first pitch
and the rays break this hood open in the
12.
boy first pitch and did he send that
baby out of here
it's the first hit the rays have had
since the pinch hit
single for pinch-hit home run by choi in
the sixth
and here's the slam yep that was a split
right there and he
left it out over the plate you know the
danger of
throwing the off speed that basically
your version of the change up on the
first pitch
is what are you changing up off of
clatty is
two for four tonight swinging and drive
deep to
right field that ball is gone gladi
guerrero with his second
home run and the blue chase they're not
done yet no
they never are they hit back to within
two runs again
who else vladimir guerrero jr
two down now grechik want to know
the chopper left side diaz
across the diamond detroit and the rays
win this one
12 innings and the rays win it
9-7 they won eight in a row